tributes are pouring in for the
legendary playwright Neil Simon he died
yesterday at the age of 91 of
complications from pneumonia
Simon's hits include The Odd Couple and
Lost in Yonkers which won a Pulitzer
Prize actor Matthew Broderick said I owe
him a career and Nathan Lane added I am
so proud to have played a small part in
his remarkable legacy Jamie wax shows us
Simon's iconic work look at this we're
here the only man in the world with
clenched hair Neil Simon combined humor
and introspection and writing dozens of
successful and acclaimed plays and films
he spoke to Sunday morning in 2006 I
find that easier to write in the in the
way most of us talk call me up Simon
credited his sense of humor with helping
him through a difficult Bronx childhood
he met comedian Carl Reiner and one of
his first jobs writing for Sid Caesars
your show of shows he never spoke up he
spoke up when he wrote it down when he
started writing plays he'd be he became
the force of nature
Simon's first Broadway hit come blow
your horn opened in 1961 The Odd Couple
opened four years later they can eat
over the dishes back in the rug it is
now one of the world's most frequently
abused plays Bill Evans was a longtime
friend and colleague what do you think
the assignments legacy will be I hope
that it's certainly the comedy and that
there's a humanity there in all his work
including his acclaimed autobiographical
Brighton Beach trilogy his writing
examined the complexities of
relationships families friends and loved
him in ways that everyone could relate
to I seemed to touch that aspect of
their lives that's familiar with them as
familiar with me making a connection
with millions of people is pretty good
for CBS this morning
Jamie whacks New York in 1966 at one
time on Broadway he had four plays
barefoot in the park The Odd Couple
Sweet Charity star-spangled girl when I
was growing up in New York he was
Broadway yeah
you really did I like his philosophy
Anthony I like to write the way people
talk yes what a novel idea that works